terminions un petit village savoyard
entre modane et lanslebourg sera
peut-être demain le premier village de
france a utilisé un nouveau type de
chauffage solaire lélio géothermie cela
consiste à stocker l'énergie captée
l'été pour l'utiliser en hiver l'étude
de ce projet est en cours et le prix de
son installation même été fixé à 35
millions de francs outre-rhin
d'autres exemples existent qui allie
chauffage solaire et stockages
souterrains c'est à dire la géothermie
georges le père ly d'affiner sur cette
maison allemande nous trouvons deux
sortes de capteurs solaires
ici les capteurs qui fabrique l'eau
chaude de l'immeuble
les capteurs classiques assez cher
sophistiqué voyez comme on trouve un peu
partout est derrière moi
des capteurs ultra sein des simples
tuyaux de plastique dans un châssis
métallique qui absorbent un jour comme
aujourd'hui il fait moins 10 mai où il
ya du soleil énormément d'énergie
cette énergie n'est pas utilisée
directement pour le chauffage de la
maison elle est envoyée sous terre pour
une utilisation
les jours où il n'y a pas de soleil
au moment de la construction de
l'immeuble de la maison des tuyaux sont
donc enterré à environ un mètre
quatre-vingt de profondeur sur une
surface double de celle de la maison en
été où les jours de beau temps
l'eau chaude circule et vient réchauffer
le terrain autour du tuyau chaleur
progresse d'un mètre chagrin environ bay
hill directeur de l'entreprise qui a mis
au point ce système nous explique
comment on peut récupérer à l'aide d'une
pompe à chaleur les calories sts qui en
est et cela pendant la saison froide
déjà une centaine d'installations de ce
genre ont été vendus en allemagne
elle fonctionne nous dit une
utilisatrice presque tous les mois de
l'année qui nous a ainsi pris jusqu'à 2
novembre et en novembre décembre et
janvier comment vous faites nous chauffe
eau avec fût-elle du fuel est ce que ça
vous procure des économies ce système
nous économise aux enviro quand un
poussin est ce que l'installation va
coûter beaucoup plus cher qu'une
installation normale
oui environ 25 % le prix élevé est dû
surtout aux tuyaux souterrains il faut
en effet creusé pour les enterrer cela
coûte cher
autre inconvénient les tubes sur le toit
peuvent se faire recouvrir de neige
s'ils ne sont pas suffisamment incliné
car il se chauffe et se refroidissent
très vite donc la pente du toit est
essentielle la température créé par ce
système est assez peu élevé
il faut donc utiliser les calories avec
soin par exemple chauffant différemment
chaque caisse selon les besoins grâce à
des installations de ce genre
qui répartissent à chaleur par chambre
au sous-sol des appareils de mesure et
de contrôle surveille en permanence les
températures à la sortie des différents
appareils
les ingénieurs allemands qui met au
point ses systèmes ont d'abord pensé à
leur pays
souvent couverts de neige en hiver mais
il pense aussi à des améliorations
adaptées à chaque région par exemple la
couleur des tuiles plus sombre sous le
capteur permet de récupérer une partie
de l'énergie rayonné par le toit après
avoir été éclairé toute la journée par
le soleil du point de vue industriel les
allemands qui font un énorme effort dans
le domaine de l'énergie solaire en
général veulent maîtriser toute la
chaîne de l'installation leur usine qui
souvent ont commencé par fabriquer des
pompes à chaleur comme celle ci se lance
maintenant dans les capteurs solaires
bon marché il est vrai que là-bas le
gouvernement allemand paye
systématiquement 25% de tous projets
solaires valable et cela c'est la plus
efficace des incitations